what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 8 of our Python 3 basics tutorial
series in this video what we're gonna be
talking about is kind of revisiting the
concept of mutability because I think
it's pretty important that we don't get
through the basic series using the
methodology though we're using and not
address mutability I'm not sure if that
logically made sense that string there
but basically the way that we're doing
things right now is is we're modifying
this game this game variable outside of
this function here and we're able to do
that because it's mutable but this can
be very tricky at times and later on if
you continue to code with the assumption
that that's gonna work out for you
eventually you're gonna hit a wall and
it's not gonna feel good and you're not
gonna understand like why you're hitting
this wall and it's like the most
frustrating thing in the world when you
believe you're like rereading your code
you're like I've done this a million
times why isn't this working this is
logical ice is so simple and you're
gonna just be pulling out your hair so
so I think I would be doing a pretty big
disservice if I didn't at least bring it
up because it's probably not gonna come
up again and arguably I don't think this
has ever come up in any tutorial I've
never really addressed this but it can
bite you so let's talk about it so
so sometimes you might see so like if
you want to modify a value outside of a
function if it's a list of lists we can
at least do one thing and that is set a
value remember that set a value in that
list of lists ok we're getting away with
that we can do that but that's not the
case for everything that we could
plausibly be working with so so what I'm
gonna do is I think for now I think what
I'd like to do is
I'm going to comment this out and then
we're gonna show some examples and I'm
gonna show you what I think would be a
superior method of kind of building
these kinds of things so first of all
I'll just comment those out multi-line
comment make some space and and in fact
what I'll do is I'm gonna copy all of
this I'm just gonna copy that up here
paste and then we're gonna run a game
board just play just display true for
now and in fact actually we can just run
game board because that it won't matter
for the purposes here and let's run that
okay so that works right now I guess I
am going to make the change that I
wanted to make but basically we want
this function to eventually return
return game board but game board is
printing so maybe what instead what I'd
like to do is let's print this is
challenging cuz I'm trying to show I
want to show an exact change yeah that's
okay so so anyways game board we print
game board and we can see no change has
been made and then if we rate word run
player 1 Row 1 column 1 and what if we
we can print game here and then after
running game board we can print game
again so we'll have like three games
basically and we can see initially okay
and then here's the pretty modified
version and then here is after the
function has run yet again a version
where that one is indeed modified in
there now what I'd like to do is change
this so we're going to change first the
variable here of game and we're going to
make it instead of string I want to play
a game
and now what I'd like to do is take game
board we're gonna get rid of all of the
parameters but none of these parameters
were important we weren't like passing
we were never passing game into here
anyways these were just going to be used
later and in fact we actually could
leave these here because we don't we're
not even gonna use them and that's fine
we can leave them there and instead what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
remove this code here and all I want to
do now is change game to be a game now
knowing what you know what's gonna
happen when we run game board and just
to keep things clean I'm gonna remove
that just so it's a little simpler but
you're probably expecting game to end
being called a game let's go ahead and
run it though and we can see here no
that's not true what if we print game
here because a moment ago we were
somehow able to access the game but now
we're unable to access game early on so
immediately we know something is afoot
and let me run this again and then so
but then what if we print a game after
we've set a game okay so we're thinking
where everything's good at this point
and then we get down here and we're back
to I want to play a game that's because
this string is immutable we can't be we
can't go and change that so so this can
start to kind of run you into some
trouble later on so like what if we were
to do this so what if we said print and
one thing we can do is we can always
check the unique ID of a element in
Python using the built-in function ID so
we'll check the ID of game here and then
we can check the ID of game here and
then maybe at the very end again so
start thinking about okay what do you
think which IDs are going to be the same
do you think this and this ID will be
the same or this and this ID or all
three will be different and so on
okay so we can see here the first idea
let's say ends and 152 the next ID ends
in 376 what about I'm sorry the first
one sorry guys the first one ends in 376
the next one ends in 152 and then it
finally it ends in 376 so basically from
the beginning
this function never actually modified
the value of game in the beginning and
that's a pretty big deal so so let's go
back to playing with lists then shall we
so let's do well print game I don't want
to print the IDS anymore for now I don't
think and in fact let me just comment
that out because we'll come back to
printing the idea of game but right now
I just don't really want them pasted
there and I'm gonna get rid of that one
actually we should leave it I'll comment
that out so then what if we change game
to be now a list one two and three and
then game what if now we just try it
what if we try to call game a list at
this point what happens we got one two
three we change it to be a game or so we
thought right wasn't this supposed to be
mutable we were just seeing examples of
it being mutable moments ago right now
we've got game equals a game we print oh
we never ran let's run game board game
board there we go
okay we we run here we do print game
here and sure enough it says a game but
still at the end we get one two three so
it still didn't get modified despite us
thinking wait a second wasn't this
moments ago a list of lists seemed to be
mutable right well what about game one
equals 99
now what happens now we see oh we have
modified the initial one now because it
again here if we were to print let's
print the IDs
see that they changed IDs but if we just
simply oh no okay good yeah I thought we
were gonna get in trouble there
wow I'm definitely hitting why and it's
not going in my favor okay anyways game
one equals 99 run that again let's see
what have we done wrong here prints game
hold on why are you still see I feel
like it's still defying me and this time
it shouldn't be defined this way are we
not running okay we're not running game
board I see game board I'm confusing
myself Oh like wait a second
okay so printing out game again we can
see here it does indeed modify it so
what are we able to do we're able to
modify right we're able to modify that
that that objects so we can we can
change the value of that object but can
we change the object itself no okay so
that can get us into some some serious
trouble down the line now the last thing
I want to do and last time I tried to do
this we got into trouble let's see if I
can get away with
I'm trying to get back to I want to play
a game cool and we stay with I want to
play a game one more thing for me to
show you guys is we can actually global
game and so if we say clips so global oh
my gosh global game what this does is it
sets game to be a globally accessible
and manipulable manipulatable anyways
it's not just to be a global value that
we can start modifying from within this
function it's going to affect that
variable name globally so the way that's
going to work is we will be able to
modify game now so for example if we run
this weave global game we're not passing
game board of course I continue to run
into that and I keep trying to run it
and I'm like wait it's not doing what I
said it was gonna do okay now okay now
it has been modified to be a game and it
gets a new ID and all that and then if
we were to print game down below here
print ID of game we see that it retains
the new game value that it got from the
game function but at the same time even
though that that has happened
it also has modified this initial it
literally changed that variable up above
okay so a lot of stuff to unpack there
for sure I also have passed in the
text-based version of this tutorial I
put in a little a little quiz and that
Daniel or danos from the discord wrote
up and I think it's actually a pretty
good quiz on so if you want I'll have
the link to the text-based version of
this tutorial in the description go
there and like copy and paste this code
into like some script or something and
beside all the X's are on a sheet of
paper or whatever say okay
here's what I think X is going to be
equal to right and then run it and see
how you did
even after like seven years of Python I
still missed one of them it was uh I
don't really want to talk about it
necessarily but it was this one here and
at least I think it was it was the I
want to say was the middle one yeah okay
it was that one and you know maybe for
you guys or people that are following
along that have nothing to do with
basics maybe you miss nothing on this
test but my argument is if you missed
anything on this little quiz or you had
to think kind of hard about it chances
are when you're like zooming through
writing a program that's how I program
by the way you are highly likely to make
the mistake so the whole point of this
tutorial has been one to draw your
attention to how you can run yourself
amok with mutability but also I would
argue we should go ahead and just pass
game here or maybe better put let's call
it game map or apparently game board
where did that come let's name of the
function let's not do that so we'll call
it game map so we pass game map I would
argue let's go ahead and call this game
map so we're going to modify this
temporary game map variable here game
map game map enumerate game map and then
when we're all done return game map now
again in this exact problem in this
exact code this is not really doing
anything special for you but unless you
can write perfect code or take that quiz
and get it right every time and always
never make that mistake I'm just gonna
argue that maybe you want to get in the
habit of doing things this way
or do you want to check it every time
but in general this is the way I would
just write everything it may not be
necessary to do it in all cases but I
would do that and honestly I went
through a good probably four or five
years of Python before I realized
there was a thing going on there and I
just always wrote code this way and you
know what it never got me in trouble
so anyway just gonna share that I know
I'm confident some people are gonna
disagree with that methodology and if
you do disagree that's all right
write it however you want to write it
but in this case if we're going to say
game map and then return game map we
will always want to say something like
this game equals game board and then
game equals game board when you want to
play and let me just run that real quick
okay what's our error this is zoomed in
like way too much for me
type error missing one oh we're not
packing we didn't pass the actual game
map okay
so game and then we pass game okay
and now everything acts in the exact
same way so the idea here is you pass
the game map or whatever object you're
attempting to manipulate with your
function you pass it you modify that
temporary you know parameter value or
variable and then you return it when
you're done and then when you're using
it you say the thing that you're
attempting to modify equals the result
of that thing and you pass that thing
and all that so in terms of efficiency I
haven't run it so if you wanted if you
were looking to scale a program to like
you know millions of connections at a
specific time this may not be the best
way to do that but a lot of code isn't
like that so and this is really just a
basics tutorial but I would take that
into consideration in terms of how you
should be doing it on obviously if the
thing is immutable we can't do it like
with a string or something like that
then you will have to treat it this way
but if you have something like this
where we're just trying to modify a
certain value in a list of lists no it's
not required but if you go through your
programming tutorial thinking you can do
everything this way you're going to
quickly find out no no no you may not do
it that way so anyways pretty long
tutorial on that but it needed to be
covered like I said definitely check out
the quiz that's in the text-based
it's just kind of a good little quick
quick test to see see if you understand
it and if you don't come to the help
help channel in the discord GG sent X
and somebody there will be happy to
explain something if you are confused
and finally a quick shout out to my most
recent awesome awesome channel members
we've got fluff Bill Michael Newman and
ace Rider thank you guys very much for
your support it allows me to do videos
just like this one so I really
appreciate it I hope everybody has
enjoyed and I will see you in the next
video